this is how some of our you feel
researches show that over 100,000
husbands leave this town every single
year
our youth are full of doubts and
nobody's answering their questions and
this is not only the problem the
majority of our youth are not even
praying there five minutes a lot of us
are sisters but there is good news
we are salam are changing this there
have been countless youth who have had
their questions answered from us and
stayed muslim you heard that right
stay the muslim we are reaching them
through our videos online regular
podcast and our presence on social media
through which we reach our way for a 3
to 3 million people every single month
yes you did not hear it wrongly
yes million people a month 2 to 3
million but here's the sadness we are
running out of funds all our work is
going to stop unless people like you
watching this video will help us this
Ramadan you can save salam and those
youngsters and also start sharing in the
reward of islam being spread over 2
million people per month your donations
can get you a share in a reward for
people's clients are praised pray their
services debates and discussions around
the world prominent figures thousands of
Muslims learning from our free online
online learning platform and people
embracing the snap and inshallah people
who are on the verge of leaving the big
comeback the Prophet SAW Allah who
seldom said that charity does not
decrease your work and wallah he will
never decrease your work so I just asked
1500 of my dear Muslim brothers and
sisters to just
a hundred pounds or more if you can help
to help us continue this amazing work
and reap those rewards for years to come
inshallah this is not a donation or a
charity but an investment for your
hereafter so click the button and donate
now and if you share this video and it
goes viral inshallah you will get the
world and have a party
[Music]